the gyro can experience what is your
opinion on the benefits of fasting in
that regard okay fasting is that look at
what let me first of all talk about
fasting in relation to cancer that's
important people have certainly found
that it's a good thing to do which is
somewhat counterintuitive because in the
later stages of cancers of course
cachexia
you know a lot of loss of muscle and so
on but earlier on it seems that we can
set things down I mean cancers are
greedy metabolically you know they
consume a lot of energy so if you're
putting a lot of putting if you have
minimizing how many calories you put in
then you have a chance of slowing the
cancer down so that therapies may have a
better chance so that that's certainly
been found let me talk about fasting
more generally that so for sure in I
mean it's been known for nearly a
hundred years that if you give mice or
rats less food than they were likes and
they live longer than they otherwise do
and this is certainly the most
reproducible and best study phenomenon
in the whole of biology of aging still
there are mysteries about how it works
but a lot of stuff has been found out
and many of my colleagues including
David have made their careers by by
making progress but making discovering
insights in that area the result of that
is that we now have something that
people have always recognized to be
rather important namely drugs that trick
the body into thinking it's fasting when
it isn't yeah they called calorie
restriction memetics and you know that's
good that's that's also worthwhile think
because of course people like eating and
so um you know it's it would be useful
then there are variations and the themes
a guy from close to here is also longer
saw us sake in photo longer has has been
really the pioneer of intermittent
fasting which is basically properly
starting hundred-percent but only for
two days a week or something like that
you know different people have tried
different schedules and all of these
things are pretty interesting in terms
of being good for your house
but in terms of increasing your
longevity by 30 or 40 percent the way
they're doing mice and rats no way it
turns out and this is a prediction of
evolutionary theory but it's also been
found absolutely clearly in data that
different species react differently to
to starvation to Factor to fasting in
particular that longer live species get
less benefit from fasting than shorter
live species so if you're doing just
right in nematode worms that normally
live like three weeks then you can
multiply their lifespan by a factor of
five or more right you sure if I can't
do that with a mouse however you do you
can get up to maybe fifty percent maybe
sixty percent if you really really work
at it none of the person you might be
able to eke out a year or two with yeah
that's right with with dogs it's been
tried you get maybe ten percent with
monkey if you get a few percent if
you're lucky that's a bit controversial
right now you know yeah absolute a bit
controversial because there were two
studies done really long expensive
studies obviously cat monkeys live a
long time and they got different results
and so the question is why they get
ephant results if you look closely
exactly how the experiments were done
that it's pretty easy to see that they
got different results because of
different methodologies slightly
different methodologies and that the
real answer is somewhere between the two
so yeah hmm and with dogs you said you
get 10% about that yeah this with
Labradors that live 11 years 11 yet oh
but isn't that normal
that's what I'm saying it's they got
about another year Oh they've got to
understand much time so fasting with
human beings you think is it's
interesting it's something but it's not
gonna mimic these biologics and what
what you believe is on that rise right I
mean I'm not against it at all first of
all it is generally good for health
you know you definitely see people
getting sick less you know regular
sickness like many infections and so on
people seem to stay healthier for a bit
for a bit longer but in terms of really
pushing out the boundaries of these
age-related progressive chronic
conditions
you know it's may be here too
[Applause]